113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
numero vente
are humans guaranteed to go extinct
a few weeks back i got a letter from
jacob austin who's
one of the youtube viewers and let me
just read it to you here
he says john a friend of mine follows a
lot of futurist stuff
and he thinks technology will eventually
allow us to overcome aging and
death we could become immortal i know
the universe is hypothesized to end
eventually some say it will end in heat
death
that aside is it possible that homo
sapiens
because of technology might avoid death
or at least extinction
imagine a star trek future where
individuals still die but our species
lives on
and explores forever maybe this is a
question worthy enough
for 113 questions about evolution cheers
jacob well
if you live long enough you will
eventually get hit by a bus
when people say that we could live
forever through advances in technology
i don't think i don't think they
understand how long forever is
forever is just a really long time i
mean i don't understand how long forever
is
it's unimaginably long right and even
even if you were to live until the heat
death of the universe i mean that
already is a number
i think it's like 10 to the power of 100
or something
which is is the estimates for that you
know that
when the universe will be essentially
dead
because of entropy that is already
unimaginably long
so no there's no way that someone could
live that long
it doesn't matter what we do that it's
just something is going to happen
and as far as the human species living
long you know a star trek type future
i'm really glad you
mentioned star trek next generation is
definitely my favorite tv show of all
times
but the
the chances of doing that forever are
also
it's no the answer is no and there are
two reasons for that first of all
there's
catastrophes catastrophes happen and
there can be natural catastrophes or
there can be man-made
catastrophes and then secondly there's
just
evolution the fact of evolution
something worth pointing out here is
that
you know the longest living hominin in
the fossil record so the
the ancestor of modern humans was uh
homo erectus i think i believe is homo
it's homo erectus homo erectus was
around for
1.5 million years and that that's the
longest but
humans are very different because of our
technology
let's say that our actual lineage
doesn't go extinct well we're definitely
going to evolve
into something else so last week i i set
us up
for today's conversation by talking
about anagenesis
so anagenesis is where an entire
population
an entire species evolves together kind
of in unison
and phylogenesis is where populations
split up
into groups as time goes on if we
somehow made it
to a star trek type future which i don't
think we will
maybe i'm a little bit pessimistic but
i'm pretty sure we're going to kill
ourselves before we
before we do that i i do think that
humans will go extinct
and not through natural causes i think
that we're going to end up
inventing something discovering
something that just
does us in but let's suppose that we do
make it let's suppose that we make it to
the star trek
world of human exploration what's going
to happen is you're going to have
people spreading out all over the place
and we're going to be evolving in
different directions because we're under
different selection pressures this is
just
inevitable evolution happens and let's
be really clear here
evolving into something new is the same
thing as going extinct
now of course there might be some
virtues and traits that we hold dear
about humanity that will continue on
into this new species
some of them might some of them might
not but eventually everything
that we care about when it comes to
human beings
yet that will eventually it will go away
evolution happens
there are some ways maybe you could you
could slow it down or or
possibly avoid it by freezing samples of
humans
you know if we have the technology in
the future to completely preserve a
genome and then
rebuild an organism from its genome that
is one way that you could stall
the extinction of current humans
that would be kind of like a make a zoo
of human history
where you bring back different types of
people from different
points in history but if we don't kill
ourselves or get killed by like
an asteroid or something we will evolve
into something new
that is just inevitable the other very
real possibility and this might happen
in our lifetimes is a different process
that i call
technoanogenesis technoanogenesis
would look something like this so here
i've got me
on the bottom then we got this guy
wearing google glass
which you know google glass totally
failed but
and then eventually we get something
like the borg and i'm sure you
are probably aware we're already trying
to connect the human brain
to computers so the most famous person
doing this would be elon musk who's
trying to do this with his company
called neurolink
neurolink is hilarious that that's what
they named it because
that's what the link is called in the
borg so
they're having fun with it i suppose i
don't know if you've seen this but
they've actually already got it so that
you can
you can implant a chip in the brain of a
pig
and we've got the software now that can
actually interpret
certain sensations that the pig is
getting so when the pig touches its nose
against something
that sends a certain signal through the
brain this chip
has figured out what that signal is in
the brain
it can interpret it and if you watch you
know
the neurolink did a they did like a a
trade show thing a while ago
where they they showed off this pig and
they showed
not only could they receive signals and
interpret them properly
from the pig so you touch the pig on the
nose and the computer chip knows that
the pig was just touched on the nose
but they also showed that they could
send signals back
and the neurons would respond i don't
think that they showed
if they could actually make the pig
think that its nose was touched
just with the computer chip but
essentially we either already can
or are very close to both sen both
receiving
signals from the brain and sending
signals to the brain that the brain
understands and that is that's
terrifying really i read an article a
while back about
people worrying about drugs like
adderall these performance-enhancing
drugs for the mind
that you know there's going to be
pressure in
different professions to be drug to
become superhuman
and use drugs to do this well drugs
are think about something like adderall
you're taking a pill you're digesting it
goes through your digestive tract
and then into all of your blood and then
it you know it stimulates your brain and
whatnot
that is one of the most clumsy possible
things you could
use to you know
change how your brain functions
what we're going to be able to do in the
very near future and startlingly new
near future is you know do a similar
thing but
hyper-focused as we start to better
understand how the brain
works and how to stimulate different
things we can just i mean you could just
stimulate someone to
enjoy doing their taxes and so you you
sit down to do your taxes you just
there's nothing more fascinating in the
world to you than your taxes right now
and then you know you get your janitor
you go
you know you're cleaning the floors and
there's nothing more interesting to you
than cleaning the floor
like we could eventually we could just
control the reward system in the brain
and
get you could get yourself to do
whatever you want
yourself to do so that's like the
promising side of this technology but
also of course
as is the case in star trek with the
borg people start connecting their
brains to each other and then become
this hive mind
and you lose all sense of individuality
we could dramatically transform what it
is to be a human
to the point that you know in the fossil
record we consider a new species to have
evolved when there's enough difference
between the older populations
so when we're looking at anagenesis in
the fossil record it's like okay
this thing that we're looking at is
anatomically different
from this other thing and there's kind
of a fuzzy line there where they're just
gonna say okay this is a new species
and i think for techno anagenesis you
know this could happen
really quickly our bodies might stay
pretty much the same i mean this could
happen in the next
couple hundred years our bodies are the
same but if
you were to take a time machine go into
the future and try and hang out with one
of the people
they're going to be so incredibly
different from you that there's no real
way to even relate to them
we're kind of already doing that just
through cultural
anagenesis right if you were to go back
300 years
you probably wouldn't have a whole lot
in common with anyone you met i mean
there'd even be a little bit of a
language barrier not not much
but you'd still be able to hang out with
pretty much anyone and enjoy your your
conversation
but if you were to go just 300 years
into the future i don't know that that
would be the case
even if all goes well so there you have
it folks
will humans go extinct are we guaranteed
to go extinct i would say that the
answer
is yes that's either going to happen
through a catastrophe maybe a natural
catastrophe
probably a man-made catastrophe or of
course there is the other option that we
will just evolve into something new
either through biological evolution or
technology
mixed with biological evolution that
will just transform us into something
that maybe we don't want to become
maybe it's gonna maybe it's gonna be a
horrible future
maybe it'll be nice for a while but
if you live long enough you will get hit
by a bus
next question
one more thing before i go i've i've had
people i've had a lot of conversations
about
possible futures for humanity with with
various really smart people and
some are really really concerned about
things like neuralink and i'm concerned
too
obviously for the reasons that i
mentioned but
the uh
i've heard people say oh maybe maybe
someone needs to stop
neuralink from doing what they're doing
um there's a elon musk and neural link
they get
all the attention but there's a bunch of
companies that are doing the same thing
there's i mean just look it up i think
there's like
10 of them just in the u.s and in europe
and then who knows what's happening in
you know china and uh korea and other
other places of the world
this is one of the weird things about
science is that once
once we started this project called
science like there's
no there's no clear way to put the
brakes on
we just go we just keep going and it
seems like we're going
exponentially if you ask me and i don't
know
uh that there's any way to stop that
i mean the only the only thing that
seems like that could stop that would be
a complete
civilization collapse and that of course
would not be pleasant
so uh yeah i think i think you know
pandora's box has been opened
the scientific method is a thing and
it's extremely powerful
and it might transform us into something
amazing it might
it might ruin everything we'll see
so sweet dreams
you